[Música]
el futuro es incierto el frente de
batalla no está lejos pero el amor como
la guerra está por todas partes para
alicia y valerie es ahora o nunca para
casarse ciudadanos de a pie hace apenas
dos semanas ahora están listos para
defender kiev pero antes portando sus
uniformes militares y cascos durante la
ceremonia ortodoxa hay que celebrar la
unión yo alicia de todo como mi esposo
te prometo amor y fidelidad hasta que la
muerte nos separe
los declaro marido y mujer los
felicitamos puedes besar a la novia
la alegría es pasajera en una ciudad que
se ha transformado por completo las
intersecciones de las carreteras son
ahora puestos de control los sacos de
arena se amontonan como barreras contra
los tanques rusos
ya estamos acostumbrados a esta
situación alrededor de kiev hay combates
pero estamos preparados para resistir
a sólo 20 km de la capital en el
suburbio de irbin murieron el domingo
varios civiles entre ellos una familia
con dos niños cuando intentaban huir
en los bombardeos de artillería
alcanzaron toda la ciudad los suburbios
las casas particulares los apartamentos
estábamos bajo tierra pero era una
oportunidad para escapar así que cogimos
nuestro equipaje y vinimos aquí en coche
el hámster es que puentes bombardeados
cuerpos en medio de la carretera
animales en los brazos de quienes dejan
sus hogares los habitantes de irving
huyen de los combates mientras la caída
de las bombas rusas se acerca a la
capital